- My camera's not turning on.
It's not turning on.
(crowd murmuring)
Okay.
- Does this seem like a desert to you?
(man laughing)
It's ridiculous.
(woman gasping)
- Can you be a total asshole
and still change the world for the better?
I'm not actually sure about that question,
but there's one guy who certainly
seems like proof that you can,
and you've probably never heard his name.
- The most fascinating
character in American history
I've never heard anything about.
- And yes, that's John Green,
an OG YouTuber and author
of The Fault In Our Stars
and Turtles All The Way Down,
and someone who I am a giant fan of,
and during this interview was
sort of low-key freaking out.
Anyway, John Green wrote a book
with some very juicy
and fascinating essays,
link in the doobly-doo.
And one of those essays is about this guy.
- Clarence Saunders.
(shutter clicking)
- Yes, Clarence Saunders.
Clarence Saunders changed everything,
at least here in the United States.
And to understand how,
you have to understand grocery stores.
(energetic old-time music)
Specifically, what grocery stores
used to look like a hundred years ago.
Wait a minute.
Before we go on,
let me just tell you
something really quickly.
See this?
Inside of this little case are earbuds
that I've been using lately.
And the earbuds are made by Raycon,
who are the sponsor of today's video.
These are called the Everyday Earbuds,
and as the sun has been coming out,
and as I've been sort of
trying to get back to normal,
I've been exercising for
the first time in awhile,
and going for runs.
And when I go for runs,
I listen to audiobooks.
Is that a nerdy thing that I do?
I listen to audiobooks when I go for runs.
Anyway, these earbuds have been awesome.
Unlike most of earbuds, they
don't fall out of my ears.
I tend to have these like, big ear holes.
And what I love about these
Everyday Earbuds is that
they come with different
sized like, gel fittings.
So I can just put the biggest ones on,
and they actually like stick in my ear
and they don't fall out.
That's cool.
The other thing is the battery
life is basically forever.
Like, it's like 32 hours of battery life,
which is a very long time.
And they're like, really affordable.
They're like, half the
price of premium earbuds
that are out there.
So they're affordable,
they sound really good,
and they stay in my ears,
and the battery lasts for a long time.
So I've been going on runs,
I've been listening to
audiobooks with these earbuds,
and I really like them.
Raycon comes with a 45-day
happiness guarantee.
Like, they're so confident
that you're going to like these earbuds
that they're just like,
yeah, try them for 45 days,
and we like, guarantee
that you'll be happy.
So if you're interested in
even looking into these,
there's a link in my description,
buyraycon.com/johnnyharris.
Please use that link if you're
going to go check these out.
First off, you get 15% off of
these earbuds if you do that.
And then also, it helps
support this channel
when you go to that link,
so that Raycon knows that
you showed up to them
through this video.
There's also a card
like, up here somewhere
that is that link, too.
That is technology.
We can put little cards in YouTube videos.
Welcome to the future.
Thank you, Raycon, for sending
me these awesome earbuds
and for supporting this channel
and for sponsoring today's video.
And let's get back to the story now.
Clarence Saunders, what a man.
- So my great grandfather's
grocery store in rural Tennessee
was like almost every
grocery store in America.
It was called a full
service grocery store.
You walked in, there was a counter,
you often handed the grocer list,
and then the grocer would
go and get all of your food.
And then they would weigh it
all, and they would charge you,
and often, you would pay
back that grocery bill
over time on credit.
There were no aisles.
Customers usually didn't pick brand names,
so brand named food wasn't
nearly as important as it is now.
And also, highly processed packaged food
wasn't nearly as important as it is now.
- The first thing this
guy, Clarence Saunders,
did was he had an idea.
- He would later like,
tell the origin story
of many different ways, but
one of the ways he told it,
he would say, "I was on a train,
and like a bolt of lightning,
the idea hit me for the
future of American food."
- [Announcer] A daily battle
is being waged in supermarkets
all over this country.
A battle for the customer's dollar.
- His concept for a grocery
store was a store with aisles
where customers themselves
would walk through the aisles
and pick their own food.
There would be price tags on the food,
which had never been the case before.
And he would call this
grocery store Piggly Wiggly.
- Wait, what?
Piggly Wiggly?
Piggly Wiggly, why?
Wait, why?
- That's a great question, Johnny.
So one time, Saunders was asked about this
and he answered that the name
of the grocery store, quote,
"arrived from out of chaos
and in direct contact
with an individual's mind."
Which maybe gives you a
little bit of a concept
of the sort of dude her was.
- Some men just want to
watch the world burn.
(Johnny laughing)
- Oh, that is amazing.
- But mostly, when people would ask,
"why call your grocery
store Piggly Wiggly,"
he would answer, "so that people will ask
that very question."
- Man, this feels like
the Old Spice commercials.
- [Woman] Pair Charmin
Freshmates with your Char-
- (yells) Old Spice body
spray is too powerful
to stay in its own commercial!
- Yes.
- We're going to just be like,
so weird and crazy that like,
everyone will be curious.
- And a huge percentage
of his advertising budget
went to ads that were so weird.
I mean, he called the third
Piggly Wiggly Piggly Wiggly III
because he felt that it was
owed a certain royal dignity.
I mean, it was very much
like the early 1920s and 30s
version of the Old Spice ads.
(Terry Crews yelling)
- Okay, so Clarence Saunders
basically just disrupted
the old way of grocery shopping.
And as a consequence, a bunch of clerks,
these people who used to
do the grocery shopping,
lost their job.
- My great grandfather's
grocery store closed
as did many, many others.
A lot of jobs were lost in this.
And there was widespread
fear about, you know,
losing jobs to automation,
losing jobs to hyper-efficiency,
which also, of course,
foreshadows some current concerns.
- Technology today could lead to 45%
of current jobs disappearing.
- But that doesn't make him an asshole.
Like, there are people all
the time making businesses
that people lose jobs on and
we sort of freak out about it,
but it's actually better for the world.
Oh, and he was pioneering
new ways of like,
guerrilla marketing that made
people talk about him more,
which is a really cool thing, too.
It seems like this guy changed
the world for the better.
And he did.
But he also starts to give
us signs of who he really is.
- So even early on, there
were some indications
that Saunders was a bully,
that he could be very cruel to employees,
that he could shortchange partners.
And he was obsessed with growth,
he was obsessed with making Piggly Wiggly
as big as possible as fast as possible,
taking over the entire world.
In fact, even when Piggly Wiggly was a
Memphis-only phenomenon
in the very early days,
he would put on the
windows outside the store,
"Piggly Wiggly: All Over The World."
- So this gets to my question.
As someone who is building
a startup right now
and thinking a lot about
building a company,
I genuinely have this question.
Do you really need to be the
mean bully founder and boss
to make a world-changing business?
We'll try to answer that
question in a little bit,
but first, I got to tell you the next part
of the Clarence Saunders story.
Because it's just too good not to tell.
(soft percussion music)
- This is where we start to see
a lot of the negatives
of Clarence Saunders.
He became obsessed with trying to
prove these Wall Street speculators wrong.
And as he lost control of the business,
he became more and more
angry and vitriolic
and really hateful.
He wrote about this, at
times, quite beautifully.
Like, once he wrote, "they have
it all, everything I built,
the greatest stores of
their kind in the world,
but they didn't get the man
that was father to the idea.
They have the body of Piggly Wiggly,
but they didn't get the soul."
And I just love that.
I mean, how much do you
have to believe in yourself
to be like, "I am the
soul of this company."
So his next idea isn't quite the same
as the original Piggly Wiggly.
It's actually much closer to
contemporary grocery stores
because there are still aisles
where people pick out a
lot of their own food,
but there are also staffed counters
for the deli department
and for the bakery.
As he's developing this new idea,
he wants to call the
grocery store Saunders.
Because of course he does.
But the people who own
Piggly Wiggly are like,
"no, no, no, no, no."
You are not allowed to use your name
in selling a grocery store
because that would be a direct
competitor to Piggly Wiggly,
and that is a violation of our agreements.
And in response, Clarence Saunders decides
to call his new grocery store
the Clarence Saunders Sole
Owner Of My Name grocery store.
- Oh my gosh, it's so good.
It's like, I didn't
realize you could one-up
this sort of self-centeredness and like,
snarkiness of this guy.
- Yes, yes.
- And then it's like, again,
he's doing this to his business.
Like, this is what is going
to be out there to the world,
and yet he's using it as
his like, personal ego-fest.
I love it.
- But that's a lot of what we see
with 21st century capitalism too,
is these highly charismatic
individual founders
who are really lifted up as
the centerpiece of the company,
that it's not about the
75,000 or 200,000 employees
working together on a project.
It's about this one god man, you know?
Almost always a man.
- My question is now for you as a person
who's grown businesses and has led people,
and I'm in this now more and more
as I grow like, a startup and stuff.
And like, Clarence Saunders
was obviously very successful.
Like, timing might've
been a little bit off,
but like, he was very
successful in disrupting
and changing things
and building a business
that still exists today.
Do you have to be an asshole to like,
build big businesses in
the capitalistic system?
Like, is that a prerequisite to like,
be hyper successful, in your mind?
- I'm not sure.
I was on a phone call once
with a very successful
entrepreneur person.
And he said to me, "you're
too loyal to your people
and not loyal enough to your product."
And my feeling about that was well,
if that's the side that
we're going to err on,
that's the side I would prefer to err on.
Like, I believe in humans
making stuff together.
I don't really believe in the
idea of these sui generis,
brilliant individuals who
reshape history on their own.
I mean, the truth is, like
almost every successful person,
Clarence Saunders was a
bubble on the tide of empire,
as Robert Penn Warren put it.
He was riding a wave that was
much, much larger than him.
And, I mean, he was a very bright guy,
but I think that in the end,
that obsession with growth at all costs,
that obsession with, you
know, winning, it ruined him.
I mean, he died a poor man in a
sanitarium for mentally ill people.
He alienated almost everyone
who loved him in his life.
And I don't think that's
the hero's journey.
(calm music)